the effects of technology on our social
connectedness is interesting because
it's neither bringing us together nor
separating us alone there was a study
done about 15 years ago where
individuals were given access to the
Internet
and what they found was that access to
the Internet increased feelings of
loneliness it didn't decrease now the
reason that happened was because people
were replacing social engagements with
time online they have subsequently found
that if you are isolated perhaps because
of a physical disability or a stigma the
internet decreases levels of loneliness
because now you have connections that
were not provided before what other
research has suggested is that if one
uses the Internet not as a replacement
for actual contact and communication but
as a way to promote that contact then it
decreases loneliness if I'm using it to
coordinate where my friend and I can
meet so we can go biking together or go
out to dinner together then that's the
use of technologies that's decreasing
and the reason it's relying on
technology as a replacement is
diminishing connection if it's used to
replace that it's actually simple to see
but not obvious at first if you simply
watch people walking they have their own
pace their own gestures if you have them
walk together you see them become
synchronized right now their pace is the
same their gestures are the same they
look like a unit rather than two
individuals the extent to which they
look like a unit they're synchronized is
called resonance they're greater the
resonance between those individuals you
ask them how they feel about each other
the more rapport they were rapport and
the more they like one another we know
this from experiments where one of those
two was a Confederate and was varying
whether they fell in resonance with the
other end
or not all right all of this occurs in
normal circumstances unconsciously we're
completely unaware of it but that can't
happen through text or voice or even
Avatar mediated circumstances it's
something that's our mirror neurons and
our brains are adjudicating it's
something that we need not attend to and
it's something that influences us in a
way that were completely insensitive to
if someone were living their life on the
internet and were doing that instead of
what they had been doing and that's
engaged in actual face-to-face contact I
would ask them what the effects on them
or whether they felt more connected or
less connected Lie I recently to a man
with autistic syndrome and he explained
that he had points felt lonely ah and he
found that it was very difficult for him
to interact with other individuals most
individuals have eye contact they like
eye contact eye contact helps people
synchronize there's research showing
that individuals with autistic syndrome
do not like I type contact find it very
aversive I asked this individual if
that's was his experience he said yes
absolutely
and you know any manner of interacting
is fine but it's about achieving that
resonance and as I asked him a few more
questions he does have a few good
friends and they are similarly
disinclined to eye contact they have a
resonance but it's through a different
means than individuals without that
autistic syndrome and so either is fine
but it's important to find that match
and so if this retreat to the internet
was an improvement because of a mismatch
knowing that well but it's a it's not
about trying to relate to everybody it's
about trying to relate to people who are
similar finding that right resonance if
they were unhappy
with the internet alone then that's that
gives them an alternative if by
communicating only through the internet
it was better than the alternative than
that I have no qualms clumps with that
but one of the features is there are
alternatives and it's not about relating
so often we think we should have we
shouldn't everybody should be our
friends everybody I meet should like me
and that's not that's actually not the
secret of our research it's it we're a
connected species but the secret of
connectivity is very much like computers
if a computer were connected with
everyone it wouldn't be able to do much
of anything it's about being selectively
connected and but finding those good
matches and it doesn't take very many
that's the remarkable thing an extrovert
and introvert can be lonely or are
connected the extrovert might take two
three good relationships where an
introvert might just take one it's
achievable by everyone